babes guess what october 1st me and sal
are co-headlining the lyric in baltimore
october 29th we're co-headlining durham
north carolina at the dooring performing
arts center you can go to
christiecomedy.com or salvatocomedy.com
and get those tickets also happening
right now i will be at the borgata in
atlantic city on january 29th go to
christiecomedy.com click the link for
january 29th the borgata use the
pre-sale code chaos the pre-sale is
happening right now it is over tonight
pre-seal code chaos borgata january 29th
october 1st at the lyric baltimore with
sally babes october 29th in durham with
salad vapes january 29th to bragato with
chrissy d what do you got to lose
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
baby just give me the
hey babe hey babe what's going on babe i
haven't been in the same room with you i
can't take that seriously
i tried i tried to turn to you and i
tried to settle but the god's honest
shoot this i i didn't know any of those
were the words
it says
like i read words and i still don't know
what the words can we just go back to
the words sean paul in this song um give
me the light he says bust another bacal
ammo it looks like buckle what is a
baccala oh bottle of moet
but he says
yeah but that's just slang babe oh no
baccalamo is a south austin
what is a bakalimo
i didn't know that he was saying that do
us a favor what's up hey babe gmail is
it hey podcast gmail.com
gmail.com email heybaypod at gmail.com
he must have emailed us a video of you
calling someone a bachelor
in this grocery store so so we just so
go back if we go back to the lyrics it's
give me the light and and pass the drug
which i'm saying
which is i'm assuming this chronic i
would yeah i would imagine it is and let
yeah the i would think it's a hydro yeah
hydroponic weed stash right right okay
okay so we know the first line when it
got first what's another bakalamo i
think that's to really open up another
bottle of moet is what i think it is pop
another bottle right which one is going
to catch my flow i i don't is he talking
about his period well he says gil
girl
girl
girl an enemy side and i got to know so
i think maybe he's saying a girl i'm
looking at a girl it's guia it says
g-y-a-l on the lyrics
i then i got to know yeah yeah what
we're on we're we're looking at the
lyrics we're looking at the lyrics to
the song of uh give me the light and
what that website is lyricbaltimore.com
yeah yeah don't forget that now right or
it might be the lyric ball tomorrow
we're going to be at the lyric baltimore
tomorrow we're going to be saying it's
going to be so much fun
dude 100 it's going to be so much fun
are you going to stay over in the hotel
what are you going to do are you going
to go yeah let's think about it why
don't we stay in a nice hotel i want to
do like a fun thing in a hotel do you
want to do a fun thing in a hotel of
course why don't we do a hey babe from
the should we do a thing in the hotel we
all go and hang out in the hotel hanging
out in the hotel afterwards i wasn't
gonna do i was just gonna drive home
because you can't drive oh let's start a
show the next day that guy's postponed
my next day is free you want to just do
that where was your show the next day in
farmingdale long i only got moved two
weeks why don't you come with us why
don't we make it a whole weekend why
don't you come with me the next day
october 2nd to warrendale pennsylvania
in the pittsburgh greater area i'll be
at jurgles i got three shows
how far is that from are you driving are
you driving all right why don't we
carpool how far do you drive home from
journals well juggles we got to stay
over it's a six hour drive but i have to
leave at about 4 30 in the morning
sunday morning because my daughter's a
soccer man that's going to be a hard
sell for me yeah yeah but we do it yeah
jurgles
the name of jergles not gerbils jurgles
because a lot of you guys have been
tweeting promos at me so you're coming
to my shows at jurgles and you have the
sign for jurgles in your hands yeah
because i mean at the vibes and i got
them
i got all this already the girls are in
my sight so i want to know which girl's
going to catch my flow who i'm going to
hook up with and i'm in i'm in my vibes
i got my money
but i bust another bottle yet another
bottle of them right now use another
popping bottles then he says could i be
your protector you're buffing every
sector what does your buff in every
sector mean could i be
yeah i think that she's gotta protect uh
buffing every second i think that she's
got a very good body every man around
them want to turn you inspector okay
okay but you don't let them sweat yeah
and they grill you with no lecture but
then powerful drill goddamn fools do you
want to see something you want to see
something mind-blowing i'll blow your
balls off google asian people with
jamaican accents the people who live in
my brain will break i've never heard of
that or thought of that right when i
watched the bob marley documentary there
were asian people coming on those full
dreadlocks
look at chinese jamaicans look at this
look
here we go get that we got to get that
stateful money we i would love to get
that safe i'd love to get
state farm we need that money state farm
if you're watching
look at this and we know that you guys
look
we have to further investigate i i want
to hit the nail on the head you go we i
want to cry left i don't want to do it
but i will say this is it feasible
it's all gone they'll work yeah and
[ __ ] can pick up your money while
[ __ ] said made up on some long time
and gave me money but we didn't have
enough customers
so china man call my telling about
marathi
me money didn't come in money you wanted
the money channel i wanted the money
yeah you want the money no yeah man me
yeah where you coming from you come from
vietnam vietnam
in vietnam
because when you go to there's a bob
marley documentary i think it's called
marley where they interview all of bob
marley's friends and families and i'm
telling you sal it will blow your balls
off because there's this one part where
a full-blown chinese man who said he
worked at the local chinese takeout yeah
who's been working at 50 years said bob
marley used to come in and get all you
know like there's foods and he was like
he used to come in and get the sweet and
sour or like that like
i'm talking about full white guys with
like like silver hair gary oldman full
jamaican accent yeah yeah they're all
part of bob marley's friends and family
it's the craziest thing go watch marley
go watch no this is chet hanks just
being an [ __ ]
oh my god
pick up the whole island massive it's a
boy chatna coming straight from the
golden globes
[Laughter]
what is happening he's like i'm thomax
is like i literally did forrest gump
to pay for this back to back with
philadelphia and he went two goals
two uh
i put my son through private school and
this is what he's doing now but maybe he
loves it maybe him and rita wilson might
be extremely supportive of jet hacks
yeah because they actually are colin
hanks is just an overachiever he's colin
hanks that's the other son but what's
the other what is he famous for though
colleagues comics is a terrific actor
he's an actor yeah oh colin hanks right
here yeah yeah he kind of looks like tom
hanks like like a lot more than that
doesn't look anything like colin or rita
wait wilson are the but they're half
brothers is that right oh
is rita wilson the mother of i don't
know i could be wrong who two is is chet
hanks
chen hanks is an american actor and
musician the son of act of actors tom
and rita wilson wow okay so he's got two
kids listen i don't i'm not hating i
don't like chet hanks and colin hanks
have like their own show where they it's
like almost like an odd couple i like
that you know what i mean yeah colin
hanks feels like he's buttoned up and
chet hanks feels like he's the he's the
uh he's the wild card he's the wild card
but i but i i think that tom i would
imagine though that tom hanks colin
hanks and chad hanks and rita wilson
probably have like a very loving
relationship i bet you they like think
that it's cool their son like we think
they think oh what an embarrassment they
probably don't though
do you think you think pimp no comment
do you think they had to field questions
like did you see chet speaking though
and they're like yeah
i get like i i think like he did it
really well chet hanks the accent yeah
so like here's the thing he doesn't
speak like that on the regular right no
no so that means that like you have to
you can't never speak like that and then
all of a sudden be like big upstairs
and then it's like your first time
you're ever doing it right right so that
means that he either does it
like in the mirror
or at home
or he's engaging people in conversation
like that normally that was so good that
if i closed my eyes i would think that
it was maybe an authentic jamaican
version no no he was he was awesome so
so you you don't just go from zero to to
jamaican like it was so good it was so
good it almost was in culture he knew
that he knew like he he knew like the
actual like that was very authentic
which means so how does he get that
authentic is the question a lot of
vacations on dad's money that's what it
is you think a lot of vacations to
jamaica he probably sent spent a lot of
time in jamaica i mean i i i don't even
know if i could blame them yeah but my
dad is worth a billion dollars and i got
to go to jamaica a lot and made friends
and that became my accent it is crazy
you know why we're judging the boy i
wouldn't ever in a million years think
colin hanks and chet hanks are brothers
what's the difference in age
like it literally it it
yeah how old is colin hanks 43. so he's
all right so he's like right there
i'm a year old 90. oh my god so they had
kids 13 years apart he's almost 50 older
than him that's a picture of chet hank
said wow look at him then there's
another kid truman hanks what who's
truman hanks never heard of him no he's
not out yet truman hanks they haven't
debuted truman hank said this kid was
one of the holy spirit there's elizabeth
and how many kids did the hanks have
whoa are they amish
he's doing a lot of hanksy banksy
probably a lot of hanksy going on over
there google tom hanks rita wilson
children wait who's truman hanks or tom
hanks children
i've never truman's a good name
truman hanks you don't really hear about
this boy we got elizabeth ann hanks
truman hanks chet hanks and colin i
guess i don't even know about elizabeth
and elizabeth and truman don't want to
be in the business
tom hanks three other kids are less
embarrassing than his son chet that's
the new york post
see but i i really chet owns it i'm
sorry the guy owns it yeah i think the
reason why people have a bull's-eye on
chet hank so it's because he's come out
and been very strong on anti-vaccine
the media is going after him yeah he's
made videos being like really like oh
but his dad is probably the most
scene ever yeah so that was the first
person the first celebrity to get
covered was tomx remember when tom
anxovit yeah i remember where i was when
coming said cover like i remember where
i was on other major events yeah like
i remember where i was the first time
that i was watching jfk the movie and
found out that jfk got shocked yeah i
had no idea i thought i thought jfk
i couldn't believe yeah
i used to i didn't understand you know
when i this is true i mean again it gets
a little kid honest mistake i didn't
know
i thought that like the it was
interesting to me because i never put
two and two together when i remember
learning about jfk yeah in school i was
like oh that's weird that they like that
he was named after an airport
jfk
like i but i didn't understand that no
of course they came to jfk dude could
you imagine being alive
when that happened
imagine like like i imagine i mean even
looking back you get a little bit of a
sense of what that might have felt like
yeah no i imagine being alive during
that like that's gotta feel like as
vulnerable as we felt like during like
the attacks you know in 9 11 yeah they
can like you just feel like oh man like
dude not many people experience that
kind of feeling so i actually it was
crazy to talk to this guy i actually i
don't know if we haven't talked about
this on the podcast but i did the opie
and anthony show uh once actually this
was just opie this was just the opi show
anthony had left by now but it was on
cirrus xm
and i interviewed i got to be in an
interview with
i'm forgetting his name
but he's an older man now he's like in
his 90s he was the guy you know like
when jfk gets shot and it speeds away
and the secret service agent jumps in
the back yeah him i interviewed him i
got to speak directly to him he wrote a
book and he google what's his name
because he was on that he was he was the
guest on the opening show oh op radio go
chris stefano jfk
book whatever yeah uh no no no that's
not it that um um
oh this all these things are how dumb is
christos stefano great thank you this is
all it is
or or clint clint gu google clint clint
sumpt clint black clint black might be
his name go clint black jfk this is it
is it clint black a country music star
maybe that's him clint black clint hill
clint hill is his name google clint hill
i interviewed him
i see secret service agent clint hill oh
that's the youtube thing i have some
silly questions what questions did i ask
are we going to get are we going to get
flagged
oh wow what i can't what i've studied
history i know that well i mean that was
a tough day for mr hill that was a tough
thing
is that hillary clinton for everyone you
ever was you ever walking around the
white house and you saw something like
you weren't supposed to like
turn down a coin you see like you know
two scientists dragging in like an alien
that man was there that man
he was there look he was here i think he
might say something about it now did
that ever happen no no that never did
happen
did it ever happen no because i know
you're a man of science but all right
made him laugh there you go
he's got no teeth on the side if you're
watching like
you've seen some [ __ ] down in that
nuclear shelter do the planes have
escape pods just in case
do they like it was there seriously like
a button that he would go in and then no
or they don't so if the [ __ ] goes down
that you're all going down oh clint
hill's wrong
he'll get something exposed
i think i think the back of the plane
opens up he believes in aliens he
doesn't believe in that
um so so clint hilda but what he did
tell me what he did tell us is that
when he jumped into the back of that
car like you see that image like pull
arrowing
pull up pull up uh jfk car driving away
because colin hill is the guy who runs
in the back the video of him
driving away i wonder what you see
that's clint hill you see clannell to
the right
who's mooning the camera way to go clint
who's mooning the camera right here whoa
he's running into it running into it he
said well that is crazy he's running
into the line of fire told us he said
when i ran into the car i jumped over he
said and i saw president jfk's brain
pulsating in and out of his skull he
said there was not a chance in hell he
was going to survive he said we knew
as soon as he said it was it was
absolutely he said now you know so many
years later he's like it was kind of
just show and protocol to bring him to
the hospital he's like he was dead he
was dead before we got down the street
he was dead he said he got two full you
know
12 14-inch sniper rifle bullets in the
back of his head like
dead on shot twice and then one in the
neck one in the head he said so and then
we asked him we said do you think it was
an inside job and he said
no
at the time no he said as time has went
on i'm not sure really what he said
pretty sick i forget like because
there's a multiple theories right yeah
there's like that it was the russians
that it would that most people but it
wasn't lee harvey clint hill said it
wasn't him yeah kleenel said for sure it
wasn't him which is why it was an and
and wait um who am i mixing up here lee
harvey oswald was accused of shooting
him but then who's jack rupee jack ruby
shot lee harvey oswalt right killed lee
harvey oswald yeah who like that and
then i think jack ruby died like a week
later maybe ruby jack ruby ruby ruby who
they named ruby tuesdays after right
right right and that's they so this day
they have half price apps during happy
hour because of that yeah and jack ruby
is related to um
who else is ruby from soho
ruby what's her name for the wizard of
oz oh is her name
dorothy
is dorothy started his name again uh
jesus lord i thought dorothy was
something with russia um
i could be wrong
this is way this is where your mind just
blanks
how do we not know what her name is
julie garland which we stayed at the
garland judy judy right oh judy no no no
judy got a lot of people talking about
judy garland i'm i know her sister julie
all right
judy garland related to jack
no no no no no no i i i there was
something i thought that there was
something
i thought that there was something
with dorothy and rubies
ruby red oh ruby slippers ruby slippers
yeah oh all right something in my brain
was trying to make a connection but
being homeless pimp stayed at the
garland hotel in uh in los angeles which
is off the side of the highway um but
actually really nice hotel but related
to judy garland i think it's named after
judy garland because i think that that's
the neighborhood she used to live in oh
no almost positive
did you ever do the thing where uh you
play the wizard of oz to the um
to pink floyd
no what's that dark side of the moon
no what do you mean am i crazy i don't
know no you're not i'm sure it's a thing
but what it what you never heard that in
your
there's a moment
uh in wizard of oz i think it's during
the opening credits where you hit play
on the pink floyd album the dark side of
the moon which i mean i'm not like this
is a big thing and i'm not like making
it up okay and then it
someone
noticed that like
a lot of the
music of the like the lyrics and the
music
go along and fit perfectly to
the opening credits of the wizard of oz
the whole you play the whole album
and it and it literally goes along with
the wizard of oz like you turn off that
sound and like it fits right in how is
that possible
have you ever done it yeah i actually
have and does it work i i did it a long
time ago and i and and there was
definitely points to be like oh wow oh
[ __ ] like that like interesting did it
come up yeah dark side of us it is
unknown who first came up with the idea
of playing the two works simultaneously
but it was first brought to the public
extension by charles savage who penned
an article for the fort wayne journal
gazette on august 1st 1995. interesting
see oh i thought it was way older than
that
if it only came out in 95 then what
about that's when i first heard about it
in college so many conspiracies with the
words of
i think it was like somebody and the
crew was like yeah singing something in
the background it was the wizard of oz
curse the truth behind the dark story is
about the judy garland classic so um uh
i can't see
yeah there's nothing
true the makeup made actor sick okay no
but there was a guy that was supposed to
be hanging
and actually played a munchkin hanged
himself on set
uh
false
scene where dorothy the scarecrow and
the tin man are skipping down the yellow
brick road singing we're off to see the
wizard the wonderful wizard of oz some
think the dark moving figure hanging
from the tree in the background as an
actor who hanged himself on set more
likely it's one of the exotic birds
that's not even the thing i read that
the filmmakers borrowed from the zoo to
create a wilderness setting
according to the fact-checking website
snopes.com the rumor has been
circulating since 89 the time of the
50th anniversary of the film it
corresponds perfectly where you want to
get some buzz for the 50th anniversary
probably false judy garland was molested
by actors playing much it's probably
false
in a memoir by judy garland's third
husband there's a small chance there's a
small chance
sid loft
he writes that after bar hopping in
culver city the actors who played the
munchkins would make judy's life
miserable by putting their hands on them
that's insane it's not funny but you
know what it's funny too it's not even
blaming it on a male munchkin yeah it's
just the munchkins just in general
probably
the genderless wizard of ours yeah
true someone stepped on toto
[Laughter]
someone an actor playing the wicked
witch's soldiers accidentally jumped on
top of dorothy's toto
the dog trainer on set told
uh
and then toto sprained its foot
wow they did say
uh julie garland did say judy garland
uh did say that the drinking was
annoying with talk shows jack so i guess
the munchkins used to get ripped on set
which i mean what are you gonna do what
else are you gonna do you're a munchkin
in hollywood can you say much are we
saying
a munchkin i think is a it's fine you
know you should call a small person a
little person a munchkin a munchkin
there catch a character in the movie a
movie so i could say you're yeah i
wouldn't i wouldn't say don't walk up to
it if you see a little person's shorts
it's like hey you know mr munchkin man
okay don't say that nah nah nah but
munchkin i know you can't say [ __ ] i
wonder if dunkin donuts had to break off
a piece
to the wizard of oz in order to to call
that hole's munchkin do you think wizard
of oz is the one that coined munchkins
well i mean involved is from what year
19 okay
but munchkin
it's a it's a native of the fictional
munchkin county in the oz book oh okay
so that's so the term munchkin
a child or short person the term
munchkin originated in the wizard of oz
and it's and it's in the in the
dictionary as a word like that means
that a child or short person well i
guess when you go you look at these
little munchkins when you talk about
kids yeah but is that from my point is
what came first the chicken of the egg
right we got to find out what is what do
google munchkin or uh
created when yeah there you go orange
origination 1991 no but that's
no yep do munchkin or origination
or origin of the word munchkin origin of
the word munchkin
yeah munchkin word origin perfect
okay yeah and frank the wonderful words
of oz in 1900 oh my god that book was
written in 1900 frank baum wow biomes
family at german origin suggested that
baum could have seen one reproduction in
his childhood it's awesome so hit me up
as munchkin with a duncan hole and let
me know how much duncan broke off to
yeah like they couldn't just take
munchkin dunkin donuts lost their they
probably got their ball suit off
i guess lawsuit claims dunkin donut
bloop oh no no
no i don't think it was a lawsuit i was
gonna say like when did did dunkin
donuts
google did dunkin donuts have to pay
wizard of oz
for a munchkin we're like
i mean i don't know
we're a crack squad of uh we should we
should open up a private detective
asians and then what good what pimp
google this when did duncan start
munchings m-u-c-h-i-n-g-s
mr donut
shout out dunkin donuts by the way every
time i cross the border and go into new
england i just wanted dunkin donuts
that's where they're from what do you
what do you think if they're i mean you
want their donuts do you want their
coffee or you want both i want their
donuts coffee i don't not that i hate
their coffee every time i drink their
shadow america runs on duncan every time
i drink their coffee though i my pee
smells like i just drank it's eight
asparagus i get asparagus clearly
yeah
did they did they did they popularized
spelling donut like that because isn't
donut really d-o-u-g-hn
i think so but i only spell doughnut the
duncan way yeah me too
yeah doughnut planet yeah fred dones
it's the duncan way yeah spell it donut
yeah like that yeah shout out donuts
shout out to dunkin donuts center in
providence rhode island which is the
funniest name for arena in the united
states or the yum yum smoothie center
google the yum yum dude some of the
names of these king centers yeah there's
there's the smoothie king said yeah
google the yum yum smoothie yeah
yeah the what is it or go go go to the
right
what was that the smoothie king center
you got the smoothie king center and
then i think there's the yum yum google
yum yum um uh uh kentucky
yum yum yum kentucky center something
like that yeah
yes the kfc yum center
yum center
google kfc yum center where is that we
my goal in life sally babes is to is to
play more shows with you i want to get
big enough where we get to the kfc yum
center where is that maybe louisville
kentucky have you performed with the
guys at the kfc yum center i might have
i might have googled dude if the joker
the kfc yum center and then put in
practical jokers yeah that's how you can
figure it out
yeah
did you do it
the kentucky the kentucky center oh
kentucky performing arts center you guys
did
that was five years ago though five
years ago no sooner i might we might
have done it sooner the kfc yum center
hilarious little caesars is that it
that's detroit you've definitely done a
little so is it right there
turn back look kfc yum center events
maybe you're doing it are you doing the
kfc yum center this year on the arena
tour can i open you guys on that one
uh vandala vandal arena google impre kfc
yum center
dan and shay is going to be there i'd
love to go see a dan and chase show
shout out shay shout out do you know dan
and shay i know shea you know shay is he
also dan
no
he does shay is chase first name right i
don't know jay i know shay you know [ __ ]
i met shay he's a nice guy a couple
times uh because i go to when i travel
to nashville i met him like a decade ago
like before they had anything they had
like a hit or something like that and
now they're like a huge arena tour that
dan arena tour shout out to
yeah
if you guys aren't doing the kfc yum
center can you talk to the guys because
i i'll open the show for free just to
say i did the kfc yum center yeah um
so um yeah arena names because now with
everything all the sponsors when you do
you think this i was thinking about this
will it it's going to get to the point
because now they're putting sponsor
names on even nba jerseys and it's going
to infiltrate every sports grinder at
some point is going to win
grinder at some point is going gonna win
the bid to sponsor they're gonna have
enough money so it'll be fun to be to
see the first nba jersey that has
grinder on it would you guys ever sell
out your tour name to a company like
grinder the grinder tour if they said
the hey babe hashtag babe fest 2021
sponsored by grinder i'd have no issue
with that zero zero ish i would love it
give us a thing i would love a sponsor
i'd ask for five mil up front on that
yeah i'd say five mill up front yeah we
go two and a half each why the hell now
we buy some bitcoin
they got the money i gave you five mil
cash right now what's the first thing
you're doing with it five mil cash clear
are you gonna buy bitcoin with it
what would you do i don't i'm i'm leery
of bitcoin i still haven't done it you
still down i still don't understand if i
should do it or not i hear i hear both
sides of the coin
was that a bit i hear a bit of both
sides of the coin yeah it wasn't a bit i
didn't even mean to say it wasn't even a
bit i've heard i've lost my shoes and
socks and i've heard i'm going to buy a
helicopter
i heard it all well i said this last
week what happened with your big invest
well what happened in my big investors i
as i said this on the christie chaos
podcast is yeah we found the story of a
crypto investing hamster that beat the
performance of warren buffett so
literally hamsters can guess that see
that scares me though yeah a hamster is
making more money than warren buffett on
crypto that doesn't make any sense i put
my down payment on my house with the
hopes that uh bitcoin was gonna explode
and it hasn't exploded so i'm gonna ask
the fans to please go to
christycomedy.com and buy some tickets
by the way chris's new house is a money
pit oh yeah i keep losing money on my
new house the pool money the heater
broke now we had a bar in the house bars
getting removed we have all this i mean
it's literally dollar after dollar after
dollar i'm spending and i literally
thought that i had so much money because
of bitcoin and now it's plummeting
the bitcoin money that you that you
bought remember like months ago you put
like like a lot of money a lot of money
yeah is is that so you holding that
still i'm still holding it but it's down
but i was told that do not sell okay so
you are less money than your investment
yes
i'm down okay i'm down on bitcoin you
made a smart move by not buying but your
your plan is to hold on to it and it's
gonna i'm looking at i'm trusting the
experts that say
it is going to go up
so just hold just hold so i'm just
holding it but
thanks thanks so much for that
for those listening i just asked you to
adjust the mic
yeah because sometimes the mic shield
sometimes i like it tilted like how how
when you feel cool when you tilt your
hat i sometimes it makes me feel cool
when i tilt the mic shield like like
did you used to do that backwards did
you do it and i would cover it oh you
did this job yeah because every hat
because i have a big head every hat i
would have would make my ears stick out
like that yeah so i would cover one ear
with the hat and then let the other air
stick out that's why i rolled did that
that's horrible
i i had no choice but you went in harder
it was out like that yeah
yeah that's it let's say something
shout out
i'm driving home i did a show up at
oneonta
college a couple weeks ago you know what
they call it stony anta they did they do
call it because it's a lot of weed
smoking which is you know it's it's a
pretty good name but yeah
i'm driving home i didn't eat during the
show i never like to eat before a show
you don't eat before you don't eat a lot
period yeah very rarely i don't eat
a lot and then when i eat i eat a lot
does that make sense so you don't eat it
often but when you eat you eat a lot in
one sitting yeah you'll go three
thousand cows in one sitting easy
unfortunate unfortunately by the way
speaking of cows shout out ronnie
sandwich grill on staten island best
sandwich i've ever had in my life i got
the chicken fresh mutts and vinegar peps
was the best thing i've ever eaten and
this morning i had an egg and cheese
with roasted peppers red pepper
sandwich that was phenomenal so and a
doughnut from pizza cake bakery oh yeah
on staten island also which the thing is
with living
on staten island is
the food out here is so good so i don't
know what to do i may just have to it's
either i'm going to sell my house or
lose a foot yeah yeah you've been
finding your new spots i mean i've been
going crazy jams right jams i love it
out here yeah shout out local businesses
shout out local staten island businesses
listen if you need a loan if you're
looking at crippling credit card debt
and you just need some money to get out
of your existing debt quickly upstart is
the place for you whether it's paying
off credit cards consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses over a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly plan
payment with a clear payoff debt rather
than looking at your credit score alone
upstart considers other factors like
your income current employment credit
history to find a smarter rate for the
loan that's what it is and you can find
out how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com hey babe that's
upstart.com hey babe do not forget to
use our url to let them know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application upstart.com
hey babe
all right babe amazon music right now
boy if you're looking for a ready lineup
of binge-worthy podcasts plus free
streaming music yes guys check out
amazon music search you do amazon music
you can even go hands-free alexa so you
can jerk off while you're listening to
music you cannot do that with other
competitors the only one that allows you
to masturbate while listening to
podcasts and music it's not just for
listening to the podcast they have
thousands of music stations and top
playlists that stream for free f-r-e-e
for free you can keep your hands free
you keep the music free and like i said
the big calling card is is it's tug tug
on those balls a little bit while you
listen it's amazon music get the app and
enjoy free listing anywhere there's no
credit card or subscription subscription
required yeah if you've never tried it
before what are you waiting for you're
gonna love it as much as we do i like i
actually do like hopping around because
you know what i do like i'll play like
i'll try to play curated lists yeah just
to learn new music yeah but a lot of
times i feel like i'm getting fed the
same stuff so yeah it's i like when i
switched up to them it was a different
algorithm and i enjoyed it you ready for
this yeah you know my love of the 1975.
how i'm obsessed with the 1975. you know
how i found them amazon music there it
is they popped right in and now lit
literally my life is about the 1975 i'm
considering leaving my family to go try
and join the 19th century
you'd love to see it start listening for
free today head on over to amazon.com
hey babe that's amazon.com hey babe to
stream thousands of music stations and
over 10 million podcast episodes if
you're bored for free amazon.com hey
babe
yeah um so i'm driving home from oneonta
i didn't need good show with oneonta
yeah it was good college kids yeah i had
to work for it a little bit college kids
it was one of those things where they
they were they were on board they laugh
a lot but then they get quiet right away
right and then a couple times they don't
know when they can let you know but it
was still it's still good but but it was
thousands of 18 year olds thousands yeah
like
like whatever like 1500 two thousand
whatever was because i did uh i did a
couple of colleges i did uh seton hall
they were a lot of fun too the pirates
and thousands of yeah yeah and it's just
like
they're good they're good you know but
it is it is like
it's weird to do a show for that much of
the same exact type of audience yeah
yeah yeah yeah get it done
i'm driving home from oneonta i hadn't
eaten
uh with my lady and we're like should we
stop somewhere and get something to eat
for this drive home because it was like
a four hour drive home right so i drove
up four hours to go did the show a
couple hours and then four hours home so
it was a beautiful drive though right
yeah but you know it's a lot of driving
right isn't it nice yeah so we're like i
let's just go to like a fast food thing
like
we're about an hour and a half into the
drive home and uh
we go on on and we find out like a
wendy's just off the highway about a
mile so she's like all right let's go to
this wednesday i got
so i get off the highway we're driving
to it and she goes
and she goes i look at the thing and
it's 709 reviews or something like that
one and a half stars on a wendy's on a
wendy's one and a half out of five
790 something reviews it was a wendy's
shout out exactly who it is it was the
wendy's in monticello monticello so pull
up the google of the wendy's in
monticello wendy's and monticello
there it is yeah
uh can you can you click on like the
google thing and see google reviews to
the right okay so this was one and a
half
wherever i looked it was one and a half
this says on on uh wendy's on on google
it says 756 reviews three stars out of
five
which still is not good still not good
whatever i looked on we looked at the
one it said one and a half so i said we
were like how could a wendy's be one and
a half yeah it's a corporate it was one
o'clock in the morning we're like we're
gonna go through the drive-through so it
can't be that bad we're gonna be the
only people there we get there with the
only people there sure i pull up
drive-through's open charges open okay i
pull up and uh i'm reading the menu and
there's like all these deals that they
don't explain it's like four for 444
choose four you know and i'm just like
hey
i was like i don't know what this means
you know so the guy could try to go hey
how you doing i'll take a number
whatever and then i go and for the the
four for the four four four choose four
i said what do i can i have the chicken
he's like what are you talking about
he said that to you yeah i go why he
goes it comes with the chicken
and they go all right so like i don't
think can i get the other thing he's you
pick four or whatever and he's like
talking to me like that right so i go
yeah man it's not clear you know like i
don't i don't really know
and he goes yeah you already get that i
was like i don't understand it so i go
just give me another one of these things
he goes all right i go uh he goes what
do you want to drink with it i go can i
get a water he's like you could
oh so i go well does it come with the
water the combo he's like it can come
with the water
so i go all right so just give me the
give me just a bottle of water hilarious
he goes all right so then i asked him
another question and he doesn't know the
answer to it so he goes hold on so he
leaves about a minute passes another guy
comes on he's like yeah
and i'm like hey the full four fourth
thing he's like yeah you gotta he he
explains it it's a terrible experience
thus far right
so i was like all right so we just end
up choosing it i drive around to the
window with the only car there so it's
already like all right i guess that's
what it is like people don't know what
they're talking about here yeah
pull up to the drive-through window you
know those like the two glass windows
that open up like this like a bank tower
there is such a sheen a thick sheen of
grease
on that window that it almost looks like
the people are like blurred out inside
like you can't even see the people
that's how filthy the sheen of grease is
on this window so we see them through it
but they're like frosted
and there's only one just like the
bathroom when you're standing there yeah
so i'm staring at the guy i could barely
see him he's staring at me
he's doing his own thing in there he's
not addressing us a few minutes go by a
few minutes a few minutes like five
out of wendy's driving through when i
already pulled up we're the only ones
there i'm at the window i'm not
exaggerating about five minutes passes
which is in eternity in eternity so i
look at her i'm like this is is this the
weird to you she goes yeah i go like in
new york like you pull up the ladies
like thank you they have the phone and i
get like i get anxiety yeah all right
i'm like how did you make this a square
and i almost i'm like i want to check
the bag to make sure it has everything
but they're like you know and you have
to move on
i guess we're just used to like new york
whatever so after about five minutes
the guy opens up the thing
he hands me two big seltzers so i'm like
oh hey i said i ordered you know one
seltzer and one uh one water so he's
like
he goes he gets about the sun he hands
it to me right
he hands me my change it's 28
change plus like 70 cents he just hands
me 28 dollars doesn't mention the coins
okay then he hands me the receipt i look
did he charge me a dollar 29 for the
dasani which is weird because he said it
was included he's like it could be i
didn't know he's judging me actually he
doesn't give me the change i don't care
so i've taken this on you make money you
could a dollar 29 i just thought it was
i just thought it was funny because he's
like it can be so i was just like it was
such weird messaging so we laughed at
that then i'm like he's not even giving
me the coins i don't even care yeah
right so then he closes but you put but
you're closing on a house soon right you
should i mean the coins correct i just
want to just i just want to tell you
don't spend money wildly the coins could
have been if you need coins i'll give
you questions yeah but i haven't also
might change but
you just closed on the house i should
have asked that a prince no it's not
about a princess just you close on a hat
you close it right right right okay yeah
all right show the coins
so he closes the thing again right this
gets good now now i watch the same kit
by the way the kid
didn't look like he had a high iq i just
don't like that
he was a brendan dassey
from from making he looked like he was
slow on the uptake which yeah which hey
shout out slow people yeah no i didn't
i didn't mean to shut out looking like a
slow but i don't even think i don't even
think he was anything like he challenged
i just think shout out iqs under 100.
yeah i just think this guy was a low
cute guy low q he's a low iq guy low iq
i'm not saying like he was like he's
challenged or anything like that or
incapable but i think he was just a dumb
guy shout out dummies yeah
he walks over and i'm watching through
the window
and he walks over we ordered two chicken
sandwiches he walks over to the fryer
and he takes his hand
and he puts it into the fryer
and he puts it into the oil and he pulls
out when one fist two pieces of chicken
dripping with oil in his hand with no
glove on no glove and then he just walks
past that area past us and into the
front area puts the chicken on the thing
and then starts to get the accoutrements
to make the chicken and i was like
i turned the microphone i said did i
just
did that just did you just see that she
goes yeah i go what did you think you
just saw and she goes did he just put
his hand in the fryer and take out both
pieces of chicken i go that's what i saw
and she goes it can't be like the oil i
go i know but he did it i watched him do
it and she's like i know so we wait i'm
not kidding you
another five minutes this is an eternity
we're there 15 minutes now between the
ordering and the waiting at the window
still no one behind us
he comes back over he gives us the bag
he opens the thing he's got thick
glasses they're about this thick right
he goes to hand me this stuff i said can
i ask you a question
she goes don't don't i don't know but
i'm not going to eat it if he touched it
with his hands i want to ask him if he
says yes maybe we miss saw him so she
goes all right he opens the door and he
hands you he's just staring at me with
his stick glasses i go can i ask you a
question he goes yeah i go
did you just take our chicken out with
your bare hands from the front of the
fryer he goes
yeah
i go no
no he goes yes i go no
you can't do that yeah and he's just
staring at me he doesn't say anything
he's still holding the bag out and i go
you know you can't do that and he's
holding the bag and he's still his name
i go you can take that back i'm not
having that yeah so he just takes it
back and i go look can i just have my
money back so he goes hold on he closes
the greasy window he leaves he leaves
for about two or three minutes and he
comes back with another guy the guy that
comes back is
maybe 70 pounds right he's he's got
not nothing against him but he's got
nicknames he comes over almost with the
shakes
he's the representative of the boss of
the other guy he opens the thing he goes
is there an issue he was polite but he
was a little bit out of it and i said
yeah your boy i said just palmed just
straight palmed both chicken cutlets out
of the fryer direct yeah i go i've never
seen anyone i can't put my mouth on that
i was like also you shouldn't serve that
oil anymore yeah he's like i'm sorry
about that
so he closes the window and they're
standing right there and he's talking to
the guy and i hear him being like blah
blah blah he's talking to him and then
he opens it again and as he's opening i
hear him go i'll just say that don't say
anything or whatever and then he opens
it to me and he didn't know i catch that
and he goes i had a word with him
and he goes just keep the celsius i go i
don't even want the cells so i get
themselves in the water back and i give
him the 28 dollars back i go he didn't
even give me the right change yeah and i
give him the receipt and then he closes
the thing and then alone he's on the pos
system himself i'm not joking
another two and a half minutes
to the point where i knock out can you
just give me the 50 back that i because
now you're mad because you're hungry too
now we have been i'm not kidding you
we've been we were 34 minutes at the
wendy's because we looked at the clock
we couldn't believe it because i was so
dead tired i had two and a half hour
drive ahead of me we're there 34 minutes
and then the guy finally after two and a
half minutes opens the door gives me
back a different crumpled 50 and he's
like i'm sorry about that i'm like hey
man don't even worry about i just drove
away but it took 34 minutes the
monticello wendy's that had one and a
half stars that's why
like listen to the stars
oh my god the guy palmed it with he had
grit his hand looked like a [ __ ] cat
catches me
his hand his his his hands skin
was just so prepared for that oil do you
know how you could prevent that problem
next time
do you know how you could prevent that
problem from ever happening again you
need to eat at oneonta go to
hellofresh.com
[Laughter]
14 free meals hey babe 14 promo cod
what did you wind up eating i went down
the road to a mcdonald's mcdonald's
saved the day they
the transaction at mcdonald's was fine
how long how long we got to mcdonald's
32 minutes no oh actually no the
mcdonald's was jumping and we were
behind people that were like like had
that we were behind person that had that
like you know when they put like 20
speakers in the junk yeah yeah and the
car is
violently shaking to the point where
it's like how can anyone listen to this
that's who was in front and behind us in
the mcdonald's drive through so so
mcdonald's themselves it was about a
five minute transaction you got what you
got what's going on mcdonald's i got uh
what do you go number two i got a a uh
the small cheeseburger the small junior
cheeseburger this is a cheeseburger and
i get like a ten piece nugget a small
fry and a water
okay not bad just give me that
wow that's what i was going to guess
right because because the accent was so
perfect he said he has to be on babel
right now you've been using babble's
bite-sized lessons right oh i love it
because it's 15 minute lessons on the
app that i do on the go i'm i'm on the
subway boom yes i educate myself in
another language yes babel what it is
they have speech recognition technology
the other ones don't do that this one
has speech recognition technology so you
can hear the accent because here watch
how good his accent see i see because
like like because look at me look at me
what give me delight
not good now look at him this now close
your eyes and imagine close your eyes at
home and tell me that this is not a
jamaican man go ahead hit it just give
me the lie then
you see the difference
babble speech recognition technology
there are so many learners well they
also have spanish french italian german
and 14 other languages yes this is just
us being silly geese we're being silly
goose is silly gise um right now if you
purchase a three-month subscription to
babel and you go to babble.com and put
in the promo code hey babe they give you
another
three months free so you buy three you
get three free that you can learn six
months of a language you can talk to
whomever for however long you want in
all these different languages if you
just go to babel.com and put in the
promo code hey babe that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com code hey babe babble
language for life babe damie mosca
solina what shall what are you gonna eat
tonight uh
i don't know exactly what but i know
i'll have a lot of choices because i hit
up door dash like whoa seriously i'm not
joking around dude yeah that's all it's
on my home screen right now i didn't
always have it in my area and now i have
it and i love it because yeah it hits up
so many food places that that i couldn't
get prior to this yes and i notice every
time i order from doordash the delivery
men and women are out of breath because
they're literally dashing to my door
which i appreciate i mean that there's a
reason they call it door down yeah i
mean i was in another i was using
another service and they literally this
other service i don't know why they
would do this the other app service that
was similar to door dash but this way
doors 100 times better is they would
take my food and throw it out my door
from the delivery car
door smash
they stink because i get that sometimes
i would open my door and my family would
have to eat the food off the door we'd
have to catch it or we'd open it up and
it would just be no that doesn't make
for a good dining experience yeah cause
doors you just have yeah you just have
it just trickling down the wall doordash
actually at for in some locations maybe
they hi i've hired olympic sprinters who
are out of work to dash the food to your
door absolutely yeah actually honestly
uh when it's not olympic season usain
bolt delivers something she lives for
dash along with restaurants you love you
can now get groceries and other
essential items delivered with doordash
drinks snacks and other household
household items in under an hour and
with over 300
000 partners yes you can support your
neighborhood go-to's or choose from your
favorite national restaurants like
papayas chipotle and cheesecake factory
for a limited time our listeners are
going to get 25 not 20 25 25 percent off
and zero settle for the spanish speaking
audience
delivery fees on their first order of 15
more so you spend 15 bucks you get free
delivery and you get 25 off when you
download the doordash app and enter the
code hey babe so if you're going to get
doordash food right now it could be
lunchtime who knows wherever you are you
want doordash
put in that promo code hey babe you're
going to get 15 15 uh you're going to
get 25 off on a 15 or order plus free
delivery that's 25 off up to a 10 value
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter code hey babe
don't forget that's code hey babe for 25
of your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply i will
tell you that there's no other way to do
food anymore yeah i don't like getting
on the phone now yeah no no they're
always like hello hold on one second no
yeah he needs to what can i get you okay
what's that okay okay say your card
number no yeah you know what i do i pull
up the thing i go i guess boop
boop and then in like a few minutes
someone goes ding dong yes and then i
open it and then i go yum yum yum yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
that's it doordash the door there chap
enter code hey babe that's all you have
to do and they say subject to change
terms apply there's no terms applying
and nothing stops
i just got laid out
that's the one big caveat that you need
to say at the end it's in red it's like
a catch-all and then you just downright
denied it
let's keep it and see what happens
now did you eat something like that do
you eat that while you're driving yet to
pull over stop and eat i was so frazzled
that we pulled over and ate it in the
parking lot in the parking lot of
mcdonald's which is probably
i would say you know going to mcdonald's
is sad you know we're always sad when we
go there we're so hungry no no no no no
but i'm not i'm not hating on it because
it's sad i drove away and i also felt
immediately uh regretting that i had
mcdonald's what do you think sadder if
you have an email hey babe heypod at
gmail.com email us whatsatter eating
mcdonald's
in the parking lot with your lady or
eating mcdonald's by yourself inside
oh inside alone inside of but inside
alone i don't i'm not a guy that minds
eating or going to the movies alone
though no i know but i don't mind it as
a matter of fact many times i prefer it
you put yeah no see that's what i'm
saying if you're inside inside because
eating because eating
listen you have eating a mcdonald's
inside alone you have eating
mcdonald's in a parking lot with your
lady if you're eating mcdonald's alone
in a parking lot you are that is the
last night of your life
you've done that and you've said this
isn't my going-out party i i walked
through a uh drive-through once in order
to mcnuggets when i was drunk illegally
can't do that though they gave it to me
they but you legally can't because i
used to go to the mcdonald's on myrtle
avenue and cooper in glendale and they
said you can't do it so we came with the
red with one of those uh scooters um
wagons like the red wagon and i was
sitting in the wagon and they said now
we can now we can give it to you because
you're in a vehicle i came out of a
nightclub in queens and i had been
drinking and i was a vegetarian for like
five years and i you were vegetarian for
five years seven years what seven years
how does he only how does he say this 40
episodes in
15 to 22. i was about not a piece of
meat fish or chicken no what was your
what no were you in good shape fish too
oh you know a lot of chocolate really
yeah because it was when i did it i was
15 so
you know it was 19 you know 91 92. what
was the reason
uh like i got into like you know animal
cruelty stuff
i was i mean when i was when i was 15 it
was like there was like that whole
movement it was like
you know this myth this like meat is
murder type of thing like lunge and oh
and like and just like you know all this
like so what was the typical what you
need pizza you eat milk products and
stuff and cheeses
yes i did but not me that wasn't she
went vegan no i didn't have chicken meat
fish
seven years yeah what was the first day
like when you ate that piece of meat and
take us through why you did it because
you went from saying
murder's bad we're murdering animals
time eating them you basically became a
cannibal yeah yeah yeah i i remember the
first two meets i ate after the seven
years one was the very first one was
drunk going through the mcdonald's dry
store and i ordered mcnuggets no so the
first piece of meat you ate in seven
years was a chicken mcnugget yes that
had to be bad for the bathroom i threw
up everywhere of course no i didn't make
it home i threw up in the street yeah no
your body rejects that violently yeah i
remember where it was was that it was at
a a grass divider on a hot like a street
island boulevard no no no it was in
queens i wasn't quite shortly there
after the order why are we there in
queens i went to a nightclub called
metropolis metropolis yeah they should
let people in with fake ids yeah i don't
know yeah i would say somebody got
stabbed
it was straight up free beer until like
11 or midnight yeah metropolis is crazy
i think i told you a story about this
before because i threw a skittle at that
guy who was performing that song on
stage and hit him in the tooth i felt
really say that yeah yeah i don't
remember that that was that much
so okay so that's the first time when
you puke in queens and then once a
second and the second time was at home i
still lived at home how long after the
first time it wasn't that long after i
started started eating meat again kind
of like not like what happened it was
like uh i don't know what happened man i
think that here's what happened i think
that i
wasn't able to eat the right way
and then i started getting unhealthy and
then i didn't want to sacrifice like my
inability to do it the right way for my
health
and i kind of just grew out of it i did
it for seven years and i'm like all
right because back then we
nothing was like on menus like it is now
no now they you could be a vegan and eat
in 20 places a city yeah there was no
vegetarian options like even when you
went to like mcdonald's you just had to
get a cheese
no no patty king's on diner in staten
island didn't have vegetarian options in
1992.
i mean i'm sure you could order a
non-meat option in the diner but no i
was kidding i would just assume that you
know i don't i was hard i was eating a
lot of popcorn
shout out shout out dinosaurs shout out
diners people in this food industry that
are working 24 hours a day so someone
can get a bite at any time shout out to
mustard seed cafe
in staten island that i went to recently
they have nutella empanadas
so shout out the mustard seed cafe
because that's where i want to go for my
nutella empanadas the mustard seeds the
mustard seed cafe there's a small white
woman
there's mixed messaging over there yeah
come on down to the mustard seed cafe
for the best chocolate empanadas you can
have
the other time was uh my my stepmom had
made spaghetti and meatballs shout out
stepmoms out of uh yeah and then uh
there was leftovers in the fridge and uh
i was just so hungry again maybe i came
home one night after having a little bit
of a drink alcohol and i hit the
meatballs a couple of meatballs up like
whoa
wow and i hadn't had a meatball in like
seven years and then today i was like
what am i doing i'm missing like sunday
dinner literally finding something out
like that about you that for seven years
you never ate meat is
like mind-blowing i didn't realize that
that it would be mind-blowing it's
mind-blowing and it almost it's
borderline
like
it's
i don't want to say it's upsetting it's
the same thing that happened to me a
couple of days ago i was in huntington
beach california we're doing shows with
irvine improv
thanks everyone that came out um the
hunt and huntington beach and i posted a
picture me and the homeless pimp i
posted a video of me and homestead in
hudson beach and my cousin
my first cousin was like oh my god
hunting the beach he goes i lived there
for 10 years and i was like
what
you're in my family my first cousin you
lived in huntington beach for 10 years
and then she was like no i didn't really
live there live there she was like i
would go there every summer and visit my
father because her i'm connected she's
my cousin through my father's sister but
she had gotten remarried her father then
had gotten remarried he's like yeah it's
like my father's new wife and kids and
everything live there so i would always
be in huntington beach yeah and i'm like
how did i not know this about you all
these times growing up you never told me
that you were in southern california for
the summers i just didn't you got to
drop one on me what do you think what's
something we don't know what's something
we don't know about you that would blow
blow balls something you don't know
what's something we don't know about you
pimp oh geez i mean off the top i don't
know um
i have no idea i dropped out of middle
school
middle that's crazy right you're on a
course it's actually illegal
his parents committed like a legitimate
felony yeah
i just hated everybody and everyone's
like a drug addict so i just stopped
going and pretended i was homeschooled
and you just fill out paperwork and the
state doesn't check on you
he genuinely didn't even graduate eighth
grade your parents
i'm sorry they didn't school you
no no but they let you leave yeah but
then on top of you leaving didn't
bridge the gap in the education no and
then i just took the the entrance exam
and got into high school what year did
you drop out of middle
end of sixth beginning of seventh so for
two
two school years you didn't
you didn't get educated that's crazy no
i just like read stuff about
coding and video games that's why you
can do what he does video games
wow follow your dreams kids
drop out of sixth seventh grade right
now if you want to get into coding yeah
this is a
parent show your kids show your kids the
way that's kind of crazy oh dude so i
wonder what i learned in seventh and
eighth that i might know that you didn't
because you didn't well he can't spell
we know that yeah so that happens
earlier did you also drop out of first
second and third i just stopped paying
attention i just was not paying any
attention yeah there's a guy i know but
then you opted for high school yeah and
i got a scholarship how crazy is that
wait what yeah
to high school yeah because he was
thinking outside the box wow
you dropped out then got a scholarship
that's like
dunking on people yeah do you think do
you think that
it is illegal what is the legal
ramification should pimp's parents be in
jail is what i'm asking because they
didn't make him get through eighth grade
does that is that child neglect
let's ask sound off in the comments
hashtag
jail them or hashtag
free them free them free them or jailed
should homelessness weigh and sound off
in the comments should his parents be in
jail should they be imprisoned and if
and if so
let's start the legal process to do that
and we'll we'll have them on an episode
as they're going to jail on the patreon
on the page
shout out to [ __ ] queen our first guest
people liked her yeah um
i think um what is something
that you don't know about me see i feel
like i share
a lot about my life on the show i i'm
trying to think if there's anything you
didn't know trying to think about
something like my mom
what
i know
um i'm what is something
that i've done
that i've done that you don't know about
that's mind-blowing
um nothing mind-blowing like the fact
that you're a vegetarian for seven years
is pretty mind-blowing you've never
actually done anything gay everyone
sucks
suspects it
yeah that's true i've never done
anything gay no no no that's yeah now i
would admit it here i've never done
anything gay
uh yeah no i've never done anything gay
i don't know there's one it's one of
those things where i'm trying to look up
something if i have any of my stories or
something like that but no
no because i'm trying to think if
like what have i done what have i
experienced high school
um
uh i mean you said my hair braided but i
told you that yeah you told me i need a
picture of that yeah i gotta find a
picture of that crazy i need a picture
of that you were like the original chet
hanks i told her i got hit by a car
i got hit by a car i told you that
someone got hit by a car oh i um
i saw roger federer's dick at the uh in
um you know the greatest tennis player
of all time i saw his full penis and
dick and balls i
i went um do you always remember where
you were when you saw roger federer's
jfk yeah it actually happened very close
to 9 11. it was about a week before 9
11. so i don't know i'm not saying the
two are connected
but but how a week before nine scenario
where you see roger federer's dnb so i
was i i i think i told you this i used
to work at the us open i told you that
uh my high school yes did you tell me
that my high school early college job
was working at the us open the tennis us
open okay that's what me and my friend
said we worked on the grounds crew okay
and then
we worked on the grounds crew during the
summer leading up to the use open the us
open is it was typically the last week
of august into the first two weeks of
september we then would transfer from
the grounds crew to be what are called
court attendants where you there's on
every test match if you watch there's a
court attendant staffed by the venue
that fills up the ice the the drinks
which was sponsored by all sport we used
to drink all sports all day everything
with shaquille o'neal was the sponsor of
all sports shout out to killer now shout
out all sports shout out all sport all
sport which i don't can't believe is a i
don't think it's a company anymore it
was basically gatorade and soda right
where the tennis players would be like i
don't i hate drinking this drink because
it's carbonated so i get cramps on the
court so they went away with all sorts
of sounds horrible idea to sponsor it
but shout out combination yeah shadow
carbonation that's fine so
i literally
i one day they said hey we need somebody
to staff we need somebody to staff
the uh men's locker room we need
somebody to no we need somebody to fill
up the water coolers in the men's locker
room so they told me a hundred times
knock before entering there's a whole
protocol which i just wasn't listening
so i go i get the oil sport i have the
ice um and i had the ice and i had one
huge because here's what happened i had
one huge cooler of water
i had knocked on the door i knocked on
the door and i won like a pawn spring
big thing of water i knocked on the door
and when i knocked on the door the water
fell off my shoulder and exploded like
gallons of water so it was like rushing
down the hallway so i was like very
frazzled but i just needed to get the
all sport in there so i didn't know what
it was like do i wipe that down the
water or do i go in and i when i walked
in somebody must have said don't come in
yet or i'm naked or no and as i walked
in roger federer who who went on i
believe he either won that year or his
name is that the you and they dial that
big one
no okay no i got another story too for
that uh of for this us open was crazy
that that well no federer didn't win now
because i remember i'll add on federer
uh uh i walked in and i saw his like
full dick like it was almost like he was
cause he didn't know anybody who's
coming he was like had his legs open
with his towel behind his ass with his
full
not humongous penis and balls coming out
and i just was like oh my god i was like
i'm so sorry but because he's european
they're not frazzled by that he was like
no need to apologize and then just come
in and then he
you know
he pointed to the cooler because they
had no coolers and i gave i'll never
forget this i gave him the all sports
were in boxes like they were like in
like cardboard boxes so he i went to go
put the ice he pointed he said there's
none left so i want to go put the ice
and the all sports in the cooler and he
goes i like them warm and then he i gave
want to go give him an old sport he
should open it for me this whole time
he's butt naked so i swear to god i
cracked open in all sports and gave him
gave us a better head
while he's standing there but holy butt
naked just balls swapping across his
legs and then i filled up the water
coolers
with ice and all sport and i swear to
christ his manager agent came in and he
had what had to have been upwards of a
10-minute meeting
fully butt naked
sitting with his open [ __ ] on the
bench with
with europeans europeans do it all the
time you know who else you know i'd love
to see butt naked like literally dream
of my life love to see butt naked tom
brady oh you gotta gotta shout out
the super bowl you gotta be kidding me
now yeah and you know it was in tampa
bay it was the tampa bay and and 43
years of age unbelievable 43 which which
meant when will you beat somebody
right no that was i love you
143s i love you four three men fu no tom
brady's secretly saying f u to everybody
with his with his age oh wow i didn't
know that shout out i remissed if i
didn't mention patrick mahomes too i
mean congratulations you got it they got
it they got a great institution over
there you want to talk about a hottie
with a body patrick mahomes yeah yeah
they got the right future speaking of
football do you
are you watching now on monday night
football the eli manning and peyton
manning show yeah have you seen somebody
i saw a clip yeah it is drop dead
hilarious so funny dude they make fun of
they make fun of each other like the
camera's not on
yesterday yesterday was watching the
thing they were talking about something
and
eli manning said something about this
play call or whatever and payton was
like that's why you only won two super
bowls like that and then and then eli
was like said something back like
talking [ __ ] or whatever and then peyton
said something and then eli goes that's
why mom says i'm the better quarterback
so he started saying he's like and then
peyton's like you're not though
but they were being dead serious but
it's like watching your brothers
but they're not trying to be funny at
all yeah and then eli manning goes and
then eli peyton manning was talking it
was so funny peyton manning was talking
and like you know gesticulating a lot
with his hands and then i was like
peyton put your hands down stop moving
your hands so much when you talk on
camera he goes didn't dad just tell you
yesterday that you look stupid and put
your hands up and he goes i know i'm
going to get critiqued from my dad
archie manning he's like but it's hard
dad not to put the hands up and then eli
was like just stop putting your hands up
when you talk
like dead seriously
dude
truthfully it was one of those even
jasmine my girl who doesn't like
football at all she was like i could
watch these guys talk all day i mean
they they get very heavy on the x's and
o's of the game so like that but but
when they have those moments of just
like them being brothers it's awesome
it's so recreated yeah i mean last week
when he you know peyton manning had his
helmet on and he was like
eli was like i can't believe they found
a helmet that fit i saw that
i saw it it's so funny to me yeah it's
so funny
so babes this is what we got to do uh
tomorrow we are in baltimore lyric uh
there's probably a few tickets left it's
it's it's it's it's almost all but sold
out but if you can go go to the website
lyric baltimore where they are
co-headlining it's gonna be fun we're
gonna and we're also gonna come out
together yeah we're gonna do stand-up
we're all each gonna do stand-up
individually and then we're gonna come
out and do a little bit of a mini yeah
yeah just a question and answers at the
end yeah and we have uh who's who's
opening the show
uh we have your boy
did we book him uh
oh yeah probably chris johnson is he
confirmed yeah yeah yeah yeah we got
chris
durham is october 29th right which will
be the same you know different material
or you know we'll both be doing stand-up
and then coming out at the end so it's a
lot of fun on sale right now too at the
deep the d-pack or the d-d-pad during
performing arts center yeah that's the
29th and then uh we we might be
announcing some more dates i think we
want to announce some more dates soon
but yeah baltimore tomorrow it's going
to be fun and then we're going to get a
hotelie smelly should we get a hotel i
think i think then now that we shouldn't
end right let's do it we'll just go back
and maybe we'll record a pod after we'll
have some laughs you want to do that
let's record a pod after in baltimore
and if you guys if you guys actually
want to come see that uh podcast live in
our room at 1am we're going to be
staying at the this has been hey
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
baby